welcome back to cbs this morning while
the u.s does not require a covid vaccine
passport
a growing number of european countries
are imposing restrictions on people
who have not been vaccinated these
measures have been met with some
protests
but there's also been a surge in people
looking to get their shots
chris lipsay is in rome where new limits
on unvaccinated individuals will soon be
in place
chris good morning to you
good morning and get ready to show your
proof of vaccination
if you want to see inside sites like the
coliseum or sit down inside a restaurant
and eat a pizza
dramatic new rules with a clear message
anything to stop another lockdown
rising infections equal rising tensions
in paris
and rome protesters are taking to the
streets against mandatory
vaccine checks for indoor leisure venues
already in effect in france
and starting august 6th in italy as well
want to see the sistine chapel
or how about michelangelo's david you'll
have to show
your digital coveted certificate it was
introduced across the european union
earlier this month for international
travel
now you'll need those covid records for
a lot more
try large supermarkets bars and indoor
dining
like here in rome now these restaurants
are just
footsteps from where julius caesar was
assassinated but pretty soon
well not even he would be able to eat
inside of them without
a covet pass and neither would brad
carlson
a tourist from texas visiting just
before the new rules take effect
are you vaccinated no so
how would you get into restaurants and
things like that
without your vaccination here in italy
i wouldn't be able to if you have one
your vaccination card from the cdc
also does the trick so does a negative
test result from the past 48 hours
for businesses that will have to police
their customers it's a hassle
but a hassle that's worth it at least
inside the costanza restaurant where
many come
just to see the ancient ruins of the
theater of pompey
says manager luciano giovanence
i hope it makes people feel safe when
they eat inside he says
and that prevents us from having to lock
down again
this past year was a catastrophe most
venues couldn't survive that
again the coliseum is one of thousands
of sites preparing for these new rules
as soon as they were announced
vaccination rates skyrocketed in one
region
by six thousand percent anthony
chris livesay in rome thank you chris